everybody welcome to Monday melee yes
thank you for joining us hello to twitch
and hello to YouTube we've started doing
this every Monday we didn't do it last
Monday but the money before we Ed Boon
who is great for Mortal Kombat and as
well as Conan stop by two weeks ago you
could find those other past broadcasts
on twitch and also on our YouTube
channel this week we have my sister Lisa
Byrne also charge you the audience's
coordinator so I coordinate all the
tickets right when people come here we
try to make sure they have an awesome
time that's right that's pretty much it
and so so I give all these questions ask
her those today we're going to play a
classic classic game streaming FPS now
called twisted metal combining two of my
biggest fears which are clowns and being
shot at by missiles from cars it's very
exciting
say hello to Beth Morosky who's in the
chat room today and hello to our chats
Hey Tea Room lates s Lee when Lee went
Chen where's Jordan is a better question
Jordan is in his office we might email
him later if you guys are lucky so we
did a little thing a couple weeks ago
where we emailed Jordan how we posed an
email the internet composed an email we
got Steven Smith over here on the ones
and twos and Jason O'Malley creeper in
the back creeping you want to make a
creeper noise Jason you can't hear me
five minutes exactly
I made a tiny little noise but yes thank
you for joining us to missus how many
merits family members work on the show
what well my husband Aaron's
brother-in-law that's all so I guess
there's three of us that's right exactly
and she just had a kid so when he grows
up he's gonna happen all right now we
are eventually gonna get to the
deathmatch because we're siblings and I
just heard it deserted but I think to
start and he will do the cooperative
story okay let's try to work together
I've never had fun never I bought your
daughter let's do it here we go we're
gonna start I'm gonna select from zero
let's just start normal
let's do it no we want let's start with
the intro movie
alright so sweet here's a little
backstory I'm a sweet tooth is this
clown and I think he's cursed
that's why his head's always on fire
he's got terrible teeth I'm not sure
yeah I think he's yeah it's just
terrible right exactly yeah yes yes
Matty Wilson awkward high-five that's
what we do
but yeah so so yeah let's do it so it's
gonna tell us a little about sweetie you
got a radio there what's up Peter K two
nine eight what's up
you see you hit Matt Theriault Matt is
it Matt Matt Furio Malfurion yeah Alley
Cat beef gangs back in town turn the
subtitles I thought I'd turn the
subtitles on so everybody we got the
Martian Manhunter in the old YouTube
chat good to see you John Jones I'd
remember that movie that's crazy
great for people in Kaimuki view oh look
at the blood or maybe it's just kool-aid
maybe it's cool Mikey kool-aid this is
really a slow burn here in the beginning
of this
oh look at that Footwear though she
probably deserve to die oh wow crazy
I think that's us a clown oh we're the
classy hero like Han Solo but with a
clown mask in a flaming head you know
I've never seen Star Wars any of them
never seen Star Wars
now the chat explodes in fury how does
she drive in a car with a flaming head
doesn't his car get a sunroof yeah but
it would just be the heat coming off it
would like melt the seats
the Twisted Fate a sweet tooth to clown
all right fair enough
this is twisted we're playing twister
Bella's you just joined us on PS now psi
was kind of great because you can stream
all these old games which is fantastic
[Music]
look his head his head is flaming in a
car I feel like it's just gonna be
problematic I get it I get it yeah dr.
Butler she's never seen Star Wars I've
never been more ashamed of my family I
just not I just never got around well
here's a question should I watch them
from the beginning no no don't watch the
first three just watch the middle three
and then watch the last three and they
come out what's the one that's currently
the lat the seventh yeah they've been
six seven the seven is coming oh my god
good lord what's happening here dude
this is the murder look like the
beginning of Harry Potter and that's
Louie oh my god I'm with someone who's
literally the least nerdy person ever
and the most nerd would you like to work
a TARDIS in this conversation
let's hear um I bet that they would be
able to escape if they
okay no no wait a tortoise
what that's hardest it's like this game
is like really intense
oh all right that knife is wait that's
gonna hurt your wrist yeah right in the
face that was it she tripped over
nothing there nothing oh man he's so sad
you know you could just cauterize that
wound with your head that's right oh
that's him that's him which mine that I
think that's him in the photo right the
only kid that survived no I think he's
like the dad or something nobody sounds
like there's pretty blessed watch over
his face do I think the dads
it's whatever those clouds are scary but
also kind of ridiculous so it's like you
know I don't know pixie tempest I'm not
sure I think he's just a homicidal
maniac that's why he's killing that's
right
Jayde's game suck what's a TARDIS please
don't start with me TARDIS here we go oh
my god this movies like true just play
the game
I'm tired of the game all right I think
we get the idea he's like this killer
guy yeah confirmed movies skip sorry
we're just gonna skip this board it's
too too much too much uh Matias are we
actually taped a close gamer last week
it'll be on the air next week so the
next clue is gamer a classic deathmatch
here we go alright so I'm in the top you
got a pig here pick your car they all
have you can see over there on the right
and you on the left see the speed armor
especially that one
wait how do I choose it X so I don't
know probably oh that one do you want
that
yeah do it and then pick your either
mounted guns or sidearm I think you
probably want my two guns okay I'm gonna
be on the outlaw wait I got a garage
vehicle that's pretty cool alright so
here's the deal you can do I think the
go garage vehicle alright so here's the
deal you're gonna drive around I don't
really know the controls okay I think
our two is mounted guns r1 is like
missiles and stuff okay you can run over
power-ups you're just trying to kill
everybody else except for me okay can I
hurt you might hit you man I don't know
yeah yeah we'll find out I mean could
hurt me with your words towards Sun
Springs California there we go suburbia
do you think I can't afford a house bear
maybe probably after all this damage
it's really gonna bring down exactly
yeah I did we definitely need sub to you
know what I'm gonna turn on the
subtitles as soon as this Australia
contenders okay yeah okay alright then
and actually X might be exploit the
so then if you're about to die pull into
this thing pull into the garage you can
switch out to another car while your
other car deals or you can jump on one
of these you're not gonna be good enough
to do this but you can get in the
trailer there's no way you're gonna be
able to get one of those trailers no I'm
just telling you right now right no
you're the one that said words hurt
uh-huh that's right even though what
cooperative story even though the
confident story I don't I need to be
honest with my team partner oh I already
got hit
all right let's go all right sorry
square square square it gets good to go
oh I'm just like a the but who are you
cooking yeah all right so are are too
well try oh wait
try al two is the mountain in the lap
try out to the mountain guides and then
are oh my god that guy's a big robots
that's not fair Oh yelling this guy
litter regular watches happy I just need
like a seven thousand twelve my god
Gambas is killed that guy he's on my
[ __ ] list
[Music]
that's a tent that's a tank made out of
a station wagon can't I can't get good
gas mileage as much well I got a rocket
or something yeah I don't like it's on
the bottom right I think have a flat
tire mating oh that's a no I I'm
attached to a car oh that can't be good
you're attached to a car I mean
earthling let's see what happening now
they're shooting any of the guys I don't
want to turn over oh all right oh yeah
yeah yeah really hard car but that's
okay that's all right goodbye for me
that's the best one of the games Thomson
you know what the triangle is really
helping where are these particular
people doing on the road they're fools
oh you just hit this guy underneath oh
yeah I'm lighting that guy up
I'm also on fire which kind of sucks but
you know you win some you lose some
that's what are some questions from that
will now take questions about our car
about our vehicles in the chat that's
true oh how do I you get you don't need
gas this guy and I see I take this very
seriously yeah you're leaning for it
there's a guy in a giant robot I didn't
see that the H guy turns into the giant
robot man here's here's my strategy is I
just lay on the mounted guns oh well oh
that guy's a dick that guy's a huge dick
why would you do that to me Ochs for
enemies exhibit he's so angry I'll and
the mounted guns and get behind somebody
and then just light him up I kill
warthog boom bathed Oh Ram damage see I
think people trust me because I'm in a
police vehicle but actually I'm very
dangerous what if I just stay back here
and I don't move that crazy I mean it's
not crazy it's cowardly I'm destroying
every tactical it's not what it is cuz
it seems power I mean it's all about how
you describe it
Ram damage 24 loving this Rob Zombie Jam
this game is totally 90s and I love it
we've got dragula going o homing missile
oh yeah I should turn a distance yeah
mine my missiles are r2 I get murdering
well my special weapon is a guy is me
and a terrific she's pretty good they
were wondering who's driving your car
are you guys what do you mean I think
it's sweet tooth is driving everybody's
done yeah
at least in my yeah it's sweet tooth
because that's the hero and slashing
everywhere where I turn into it or you
yeah cuz then you can ramble yeah yeah
when you when you're when your things
come together yeah there you go just
ramble 60 damage that's 60 neighbors to
me or I don't know what it tells you the
damage I'm killing this guy doble people
are asking if you've heard about like
the silent hill's thing she hit pause oh
you did alright good alright well change
your guy then change your guy oh you
just picked two axles so use this say
you're in a hundred percent so hit X
there we go wow you're way smarter than
I thought
I love how you're like just a little bit
smarter and you're like suck it by the
way I'm about to die I got to go do what
you do better go recharge gotta go
recharge baby I'm not good enough
okay just relax you know what I'm Doug I
try to get behind the health strike I
didn't say anything but I'm totally
gonna get destroyed here you're gonna
have to carry us through the rest of
this level dude I got it
dude turn it to an Oreo and I'm gonna
dunk that here we go
road boat bring it on [ __ ] Road bugs
here oh please oh I just caught ya
there's lightning this dude here I'm on
top of this guy I don't want to go back
to the garage man I want to get out of
the garage thanks
if the brakes will fly right by
I think it might be like try triangle on
top triangle oh no it might be it's
probably your heart - it's probably our
to how your ro - since your special move
it oh you think I can't do it all the
time
no no you need to it you know research I
bet it's a special weapon ability I got
some player in this lecture I know it's
bad I think it's good
killed road boat killed myself or
opponents let's find some bad guys yeah
why don't you like help me for once kill
death warrant don't worry about it just
killing everybody oh I'm in the help
truck I'm in the help truck Xining don't
that milk it's like that mount baby when
I was a bad guy oh I'm gonna shove this
missile so far up somebody's tailpipe
and by that I mean what Thanks great
no-look high-five Oh miss me who's on my
ass
Oh bring it who's shooting me you're so
dead how do I turn around damn you oh I
just dunk the hell out of that guy he's
like soggy you know like when you leave
an Oreo ain't too long and it's like
soggy but kind of great cuz of the cream
holds it together maybe eaten too many
Oreos in my life just gotta say
boo humming this alone doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you're up top man my
homie mess is gonna take you out oh yeah
it's going to how is he way out there Oh
Rio Oh reow
Oh reow I'm lighting this dude up I got
a shotgun get ya right
Oh can you do a big robot yeah hey how
about the real like a house it Oh out of
the air by the way oh oh my god don't
the [ __ ] out of that guy
where we at here where we at where we at
I still hadn't seen any bad guys you
haven't killed a single person it was
like I'd like to chat - no she'd kill a
single read you want to go towards the
red arrows man I literally see no red
arrows dirt oh yeah I guess there are no
no in there on the left seat ah kill
road kill don't worry about it just
taking care of every single bad guy in
this game yeah it's cooperative stories
over here oh come in little guy please
kill one person please get here thank
you please get one person just do you're
stuck oh that's a fun I might just be
stayin here
oh that's the help truck um yeah dude
you can't shoot the hell truck turning
on this car
all right where we at where we at ah yup
we won your team slash woody I'm in the
water yeah exactly dr. Butler escort
mission this was totally an escort
vision all right let's continue the
cooperative story oh yeah good lord
close gamer florins damn close Kimber
for what game I can't tell you but it is
a very popular game it's a sequel uh
okay you can pick no you want to pick a
different guy I'm going out login and I
you know I gotta say man why why screw
with what works I'm gonna be the Popo
that's what I am yeah do it well your
team Popo yeah do it will do katene Popo
and then mate road boat rowboat yeah I'm
out of guns I was gonna go uh laptop
girl this is Beth murasky everybody to
do something they want you to wait could
you with she's not your puppy how do you
she's our puppet so this guy here's the
deal this guy Calypso has all these set
up all these deathmatches for us for
some reason we don't know that's so nice
of it yeah well it's a nice guy
it's got like a cruise director on a
boat but you know what here's the thing
with this side it is but with cars
here's the thing you can get her file of
stuff so be careful okay
positive those balls exactly just I'm
not gonna do well yeah exactly
we'll see on a scale of two to whatever
is my favorite color banana I like the
banana is honestly I like a little bit
of a green banana
and I'm generally a fruit I kind of like
my fruit unripe I like a crunchy fruit
I don't like soft fruit hashtag no soft
fruit is what I'm dealing with
what about you guys oh yeah fair enough
mango ginger here before I went gray no
I did not have ginger hair I had like
dark dark oh it's on like okay so now I
have different controls right yeah okay
so here's the thing so square is gonna
drive you around r2 is gonna be your
special move which is a guy who comes
out of a turret turn very what are you
using that I mean a circle kind of is
the break and you can I got a turn while
you're stopped if you want but I just
keep driving around and then r1 well our
one way chief r1 at once kind of helps
you are one selects your lighting that
guy up just circling and just destroying
oh I'm going upwards and onwards yep you
got it also like the thing really
changes which is crazy
well that completely wasted that goodbye
I'm just gonna push a lot it but I'm not
gonna try well don't just push the
buttons do you my driver look what's
happening what's what is happening I'm
on top of it yeah you killed anybody cuz
it doesn't matter now my fire with
desire and you don't want to be on fire
that's a bad if you gotta fight too bad
no good dude yeah but you don't want
your car to be on it you know your car
to be on fire so are the are the r1 l1
select whatever weapon you want and then
the twos
do it need to find
there we go
there you go get him get him get him get
him get him get him
oh that sucks that sucks that's I killed
someone
yeah nice work I don't that don't it
don't get doubled ugh rain damage do you
love me some good Ram damage oh oh this
dude yeah hell yeah man oh what happens
when you do the other joystick what do
you mean that's good for me to know we
like back uppers oh yeah
turbo retards boom and boom yeah that's
actually I am fighting this tiga
Jesus chupa has this question what's the
way of escape to kill everybody
distraction maximum actually you're
trying what you're trying to do is
escape Calypso's called clutches this
guy calypso he's a real dickwad
he's a real dill weed and he he's
captured all these people and he's
captured all these people and forced
them to fight to the death
we're one of these people so we are
trying to get our freedom from calypso
and his [ __ ] you know running man
it's kind of a running man but with cars
yeah you see running man and you haven't
seen Star Wars what I mean I applaud
your priorities yeah it's a great movie
that's kind of like I said running game
waiting freaker's running man it's not
running game you already screwed it up
who's been precursor to like oh this is
gonna be good the movie Hunger Games you
know what you're right you're saying a
lot of true [ __ ] but it's just a little
kid sure you know I went to go see the
first Hunger Games movie and the
electricity went out in theatres whoa I
was like listen guys yeah murdered 16
people
someone says Aaron sister seems fun you
can fight her more often yeah look at
them apples
thanks Freddy yeah let's now look at
those apples too close those apples are
not quite right there huh dude I need to
kill I am like I got a million bad guys
who come over here you are come over Oh
Oh like I just ran away like a little
baby
[Music]
bossman sparkling wants to play what
game are you most excited for oh you
know what's interesting is there's a lot
of great games coming out I'm very
excited for well I just got a 3ds which
is pretty great and I've been playing
Xenoblade Chronicles which is awesome
playing that the game I'm looking for
the most of coming out it's a good
question
Witcher 3 is coming out can't wait for
that it's gonna be fun
we halo obviously you dope this is super
nerdy but state of decay was one of my
favorite games I played the crap on a
state of became very creepies one of my
favorite like super creepy games you
haven't played it it's basically like
kind of like zombie survival it's a
little bit like GTA and like it's kind
of like an open-world situation but it's
it's a lot like of like resource
management which also makes it crazy and
like your people can die very easily
it's not the one where you're like you
got freaked out by it yeah I get really
an honest-to-god scared like this around
yeah yeah really honest to gods really
scared me and and so there's a new state
of decay out or it's coming out and I'm
just super excited right here you guys
are play state of decay anyway no chat
rooms you guys are play state of decay
really fun great game
how many babies I got all of them I got
Xbox 360 Xbox one ps4 I got just got 3ds
got the we got the we you know I don't
have Wii U but we have one here at work
so basically sometimes I'll quote
unquote borrow it for a few days on end
legends Hyrule is great or Hyrule
warriors I'm sorry for if you're looking
for a sweet video game you know now I'm
in your boat I can't find anybody weird
right yeah what are you guys looking
forward to chatroom what's everybody so
I got all these missiles that need to go
up somebody's ass
what does everyone looking forward to in
the chat room and also what game should
we play with I mean what games you want
to see us play with gun
okay Mass Effect oh you know what I
haven't played into mass effect games
but I should oh you put you talking
about silent hill's that it's like not
happening
oh yeah that's true that's crazy now and
I guess Konami now is down with like
what did you say see they D listen
themselves out of the stock exchange
yeah so like are they just like if the S
hit in the after what like just a US
stock exchange creeper says Jason about
Cooper sighs our financial advisor Ellie
that's insane we played we played PT
which is really really fun
yeah and Silent Hill is an amazing
series and I can't believe oh wait
that's player two sorry
yeah that's crazy I'm super bummed about
that that's I wonder what happened if
anybody has any insider info let us know
but yeah that is a huge bummer it's I
can't believe that happen right there
right there but that's me
the most of its crazy behind the scenes
flight skillet right there's something
but yeah it is a bummer and the video
game world is poorer for it to say it's
up here
ah kill them yeah yeah that's terrible
I can't with a new way to high-five you
guys want to know how to do it it's
called the Cobra here's how it works you
start like this right like so and then
you come in like one like that right
yeah oh look at that pain oh that's how
you do it that's next-level high-fiving
this summer bring it it actually this
summer we do is this and he come down
with little tangles I'm into the tingles
this summer uh the postman says they
feel like Beth is ignoring you she's now
got another chat room to deal with she's
got two chattering exactly plane escape
game had Lita Ford he says what's an
escape game Hadley but what would be an
escape game like a box-boy I put in
playing box boy which is pretty great
video 3ds
I choose your guy I'm sticking with I'm
sticking I'm sticking with my old old
standbys octopus father Octodad is great
played some Octodad question for Aaron's
sister did she ever do a children's
program called activity TV Wow she did
crazy what is your favorite prize you
have with a Comcast uh-huh Comcast my
sister did a crafting Evangeline my
event Lisa we I have invited Jordan to
do to play games multiple times he
doesn't want to do it for a lot of
reasons but he said he would stop by at
some point in the future on a Monday
melee so maybe next week we'll see which
what here's a question an honest-to-god
question for you guys what do you want
to see Jordan play so tell Beth hashtag
Jordan play hashtag Jordan play and then
say the game and then we're trying to
get Jordan to play again does anyone
ever play like uh dancing games like
just dance yep you'll play we haven't
played it on here because we don't have
a lot of room
a lot of room but Conan did play didn't
you yes Alex Morgan I've got an old
Conan voice but yeah there is a close
gamer with Alex Morgan that is offline
because we don't have rights in music
[Music]
alright we're in this winter in the city
[ __ ] let's do it oh whoa there goes
really fast yeah Barbie adventure that
would be really fun you know maybe we
should have Jordan on for a Monday melee
and just play a bunch of games instead
of doing one that might be the way to do
yeah hashtag Jordan play what games you
what is he well back to my sister
inactivity TV she does she has done a
lot of activity I did pretty great if
you need a party tips or ideas how to
make stuff for your activity TV is do
way to go I'm just collecting weapons to
[ __ ] just stick up someone's are you
what it's probably I'm outside the flame
and it's no I think it's me
that's crazy that you can go outside the
thing well I just got drownded water oh
that's got to be using July just destroy
onion lighting these fools
oh you know what oh you have to keep
going I see you got to keep going to the
location well where am I now
downstairs I'm on the tracks what am i
doing where am I going serious wait out
of cage I need to get back into the kid
for the hell - KJ your red cage
we get screwed here we go back upstairs
Oh see now I'm out of the kitchen
okay now I'm back to my kid believe
you're not in the cage
yeah I'm trying to get the Kaiser with
that cage at me that's weak cage action
back in the cage like the gage oh you're
all gonna wish I wasn't in the cage I'm
in the nick cage that's me I want to be
inside I want to be inside Nick Cage
like you know he eats me yourself
it's a weird fetish like that I don't
talk about the battle I talk about just
no just you need to accept me as a
person and as a person I want to be
inside the cage so that in his belly
what kind of city is this by the way
gotta get back in that cage there's a
cage see the cage so why do you guys use
your triangle specials what is the
triangle special okay oh oh
kamikaze does nothing fascinating yeah
oh wow
oh I'm on fire this time I am chess
player one absolutely killing this guy
Nic Cage is about to move guys
best Nic Cage movie go don't say wicker
maybe because that's not true rock the
rock oh it's greatly rock is classic
you've seen the rock and you haven't
seen Star Wars just reiterate this sucks
by the way ticket office stop shooting
me faceoff next faceoffs pretty good oh
you know what go give Nick Cage Hearts
the Empire kids good he's also been in a
lot of bad news why they get more time
yeah I gotta get to that cage I'm trying
to return to the cage I'm out of the
cage I'm not a dirty boy I'm gonna die
here
yeah I know I'm taking damage stop
saying you really you think so don't
worry I got you I can too oh my god I'm
gonna die kisses
back how do I get where is the goddamn
dude I'm definitely you kill me
keeps moving I need is to get in I died
our team got destroyed don't worry don't
worry I got this I got this I would
carry on let's try again
sorry what you think I can't carry that
I can't believe I died but then I can
because I'm the only person doing
anything in this TV very good it's gotta
use up a lot of electricity [ __ ] here we
go let's do it alright now I know the
rules of this game yeah we just started
how did you get out of the cage already
so I'm not good with the tourney many
there live
here's my problem it's I feel like I'm
moving so fast but I don't know who I
can target you need like right now
you're sweet flamethrower crisis back
and roll you know right
so no wait we gotta get boy just put
that full store on fire sorry
don't apologize these people are
don't fall down in the thing don't fall
down in the thing this is why I wasn't
that gauge before you're not oh yeah I
am in the cage oh now that's kind of
cool if I hit triangle what happens guys
then you get a belly-to-belly oh we're
trying to do this more often it's tough
though because you can't stay in the
carriage
just drive around down here this is
actually kind of nice down here quiets
that one's down here at my house with
people there's a bunch of weapons
oh that's ricochet outside the cage you
know what I don't like to be caged in I
like Nick Cage I like Nick Cage but I
don't like to be caged in alright here
we go I'm going up going to get that
cage coming out full force
gotta get that cage get me in that cage
in the cage what up now oh I'm all up in
this cage yep
yeah crimson fury eating guess what
happens when I step into the cage [ __ ]
dump that milk oh my god
shot that guy right in the face there's
all these sometimes crazy things there's
like shotgun doesn't dumping yeah oh
that's the guy that turns in the robot
that guy's [ __ ] by the way I hate
that guy
wait why aren't we that guy you could be
that guy I would never
I think you would I think it does it
automatically shoot forward and backward
look at this I'm just owning this guy
shooting through this dude oh there we
go
yes
yes now stream it on the PS now I'm kind
of like I gotta say I like the PS now
because it's a lot of older gains an
older games have like split-screen co-op
and a lot of new games don't which
really pisses me off like everybody now
it's like all network connection like
[ __ ] it's like dude this is super
fun like why can't you make oh now we're
back up here this is bad this is where I
got killed last time just ice just ice
my car don't do two on the ice jail and
kill him kill him he's a robot now he's
a robot now he's a robot that was good
yeah work together don't we've been
doing well I let us down I just want you
to know that cage is about to move I
gotta get off this ice this is how I got
screwed last time got trapped in the ice
I got a sticky bomb on me this is not
gonna be good
where is that cage it's back this way
is up here
it's down it to the right this is
exactly how I get straight left yeah
dude I know it's yeah I think it's to
the right it's something to the right
it's C it's where it's where like that
that that that square is C on your map
taking damage I don't know I don't think
too great unfortunately we just got back
from break so yeah so I'm Steve stocking
down the hall yeah I know I'm outside
the goddamn area there we go
boom I'm in the air and I'm letting some
Buffalo's up yeah I don't think he's
gonna come by today I'm sorry guys but
next week maybe we should we tell people
maybe we should try to plan out well
maybe we should try to do the Jordan
play thing yes again if you want to see
Jordan play a game hit us with hashtag
Jordan play and the game and next week
yes exactly
all the cage moved
I'm going for the that's alright out of
that cage too tough let's change
vehicles okay
I think the vehicles are killing us
Jordan play dance dance revelution
that's great TV it's a busy day that's
why her on a ps3 it is a busy day all
right here we go
I'm doing something a little faster I
need something quicker
the Kamikaze is really fast I'm gonna go
kamikaze we want kamikaze then I'm gonna
go like I'm ever gonna be able to get to
the second guy here boy how do you get
to the second guy you that's how you go
to the garage remember oh I see do you
like the holiday Jordan plays telltale
Game of Thrones
you know I haven't seen that telltale
had the Game of Thrones game we should
play that that would be fun we're gonna
look we're gonna look that up that would
be kind of fun because telltale is
Walking Dead series amazing and if you
haven't played it's all about making
like choices like moral choice it's very
cool Jordan play et for the 2600 yes
exactly
Jordan play dance answer I've seen a lot
of dance s revolutions farming simulator
cone and play truck simulator Jordan
plays cappuccino machine oh my god this
is this is like crazy yeah
oh wait that's you sorry boo this guy's
got a flamethrower let's go yeah yeah
just need somebody to shoot
I'm not educational
I got destroyed by somebody just that I
don't know if kamikazes gonna do oh my
god this guy is just getting absolutely
wrecked what alright your battery got
disconnected what you think got this
connector they've got a plug in oh sorry
review the face plug in oh my god okay I
don't even notice that my I know what if
I didn't tell her oh yes anybody have
any questions wait yeah no no - did you
know there's a Telltale's Jurassic Park
no I didn't - all right let's go
can you play yeah yeah there we go dude
the cage
a shot get in the cage mofo you are like
the worst [ __ ] talker ever hey everybody
yeah I would like light the fire
I'm I this is level is killing me
this cage thing is garbage oh we're not
makes-- again I know which version of
prison metal I might just be twisted man
it's not twisted metal black I love that
oh I just Oh blame it I'm just literally
just shooting everything right now at
these guys
all right I see a little bit oh that was
bad when I happened that was oh I got to
run to ability I need to get into the
where is the cotton cage dude I'm
getting lit up right now where's the
cage oh those meals no dude I was gonna
play let's get up in that cage oh this
is the part that sucks this part sucks
although now I feel like I'm a little
better prepared
I'm going for this hell oh whoops help
isn't there let's appear machine-gun
doesn't do it does a little bit I need
lots of help like right all right yeah
this is apart this sighs I'm waiting up
here all right this is the one that
sucks this long that we always get
killed so we just follow these guys they
know where to go I need
this is the tough one
I see the cage
Oh
am I in the cage I'm not in the cage I'm
about to die I'm not in the cage you got
to follow all the dudes I'm in the cage
but I'm about to die I'm outside the
cage I'm dead damn it oh my god
poop rest koala thank you so much for
joining us we do have a twitch and we're
streaming on YouTube again this is my
sister Lisa berm
Beth Morosky in the chat room right now
we're gonna try to get Jordan to play
next week Jordan shlonsky so use the
hashtag hashtag Jordan play along with
the game you want him to play I love it
maybe we should try a little deathmatch
action all right you try some deathmatch
the cage sucks we hate the cage we hate
the cage cage the worst who Jordan plays
out last or any horror game on oculus
amazing yes yeah twisted metal
this is twisted metal streaming on the
PS now service and it's like classic I
think twisted metal all right here we go
let's go back I mean I know that's a
mass but teeth are terrible right
deathmatch we're gonna go three players
oh if Steven was back when you do four
players and we do that cuz three players
I think this is gonna cover one of the
things but let's do it all right
we're dying light would be fun sky got
moves feet yeah we can definitely play
more blood warm absolutely all right
let's try yeah what what where should we
go here grindhouse
ghost town gulps that sounds scary yeah
let's do that
all right ghost town Gulch it is right
here we go uh murasky
The Creeper will talk to you in the chat
room maybe
murasky you're done now we understand
that best thing is going to be covered
by our faces but that might be okay what
they're not really gonna be able to see
you play oh because it's covered by I
think nobody sees anyway
exactly wait what are the judge Jesse G
just goes no Beth no the main buttons
are okay are - does your special R 1 and
L 1 kind of select what special move L 2
is machine guns squares gasps and I
think that's it yeah and then circles
like whatever oh man we unlocked a bunch
of guys like you be roadkill this is
awesome I'm gonna be a helicopter I'm
gonna be holy man with it for you you're
gonna be what helicopter oh my god
you're a helicopter it seems unfair go
for it though going Road did you select
your guy are you working there oh yeah
juggernaut I'm gonna junk our dog this
time oh yeah Maxie slim no no just
remember I don't know if there is a
second one okay
crimson fury
fury junkyard dog where's my boy outlaw
I'm sick I'm singing with this side this
guy I love it
comedy games should be avoided he'll
face doom uh yeah yeah it's hard it's
kind of hard to poke fun at a comedy
game but doesn't mean Leisure Suit Larry
it would be really fun orbital I love it
ooh lucky head ass a Mario Party would
be really fun all right here we go
oh you know it it might only be us three
should I make it more people than us
three yeah I'm going back I'm going back
I'm going back
all right here we go I guess it's just
us three
I love you in a helicopter I know
how do we even kill them I don't know
yeah your Oh oh my god oh my god bet you
split me I'll let you on the
Ghostbusters card I mean you're liking
the ecto staying Oh
okay he was napalm
I'm just up vet's ass with this machine
Oh
napalm and backup
we're just like fights this guy very
effective yeah
oh you guys you're back nice O'Malley
fixed it fixed in screen thanks Emily
hashtag thanks Ovalle
hashtag creeper style helpful
what's the Ricochet yeah I love this
game
killing it I don't know all right
someone's about to kitty ah
a lot of blind alleyways in this town
designed this terrible town city
planners need to be
yup light it up light her up like a
barbecue boom how about some fire
scarecrow hahahaha oh my god Beth has
never been dunked as much as I'm dunking
her oh now to take this chopper out of
the air the copters are really bad yeah
love to take you up I can read
[Music]
it's hard to hit you with a missile it's
very difficult to control yeah I can see
her like I'm gonna be hard enough to
shoot just the car now you're driving
along the street you can use the right
stick to aim kind of a little bit yeah
that's not
how do I knock you out of the sky kidney
palm you can I can I beat palm somebody
in the air not really
wait you're back best baton oh my god
wait a second it's jump you're throwing
it like tracks him down and kills them
I'm gonna get this pulling you on the
sky man take her down
I could tell pretty great for me and you
know go on a weapon collection run look
ghost town Gulch man being lit up right
now I do like how it kind of Christian
Bale Toxie in this
I got a stalker missile a stalker
missile right
I can see I can just see like the
chopper like floating over me miss
teracle thank you be on the eve I got
some homing missiles like if you honey
I'd like to la le please copter what's
Erin's real job besides playing video
games you cared
yeah that's a good question I thought
you gummy
oh I got killed I killed you ha good job
coming back in the road boat there's one
minute left left I think that's too bad
I'm woman on left
thank you for stop calling me girls one
of the i-team in 19 there's go get them
Gaines they said there we go oh now
you're in big trouble to death
no choose your death oh wait there's a
person over there there's maybe I
wouldn't doubt run him over helicopters
helicopters exhales [ __ ]
well what was everybody's first car they
ever had what is it nice chat room what
was your first car you ever had if you
don't have a car and what car do you
want wheat was your first car lease ah
Geo Prizm geo prints Harry link oh the
periwinkle blue Geo Prizm that card like
driving a surfboard in the rain so like
one time you borrowed that car and
parked it underneath a tree of it's
right 400 Birds that's right
it was by accident it was so covered in
bird food that we took Fellig mom took a
picture of it yeah days insane even our
mom had to cram it that's like
incredible 97 97 Monte Carlo I killed
myself a beauty our comeback to outlaw
can't be I can't kill with our oh yeah
yeah 2013 that's your first car Jaguar
didn't know Paris Hilton's in the chat
yeah look at this
this part turns into that thing
where is it I gotta get back in the cage
man get in the cage Rooter to change
dude in the cage
here we go coming back to that cake whoa
what is that who is the semi-truck it's
me yeah sounds rough can't wait to blow
it up that was like my special thing I
wasted of course
ooh I got some homing missiles for you
that was it that's it oh wait just let
me pause and replay did your thing die
hit circle
no exit game no exit game no game no
game no thanks everybody press circle
right now with circle here we go all
right here we go we're back all right
nobody even somehow I think it wasn't a
choppers Falls
I'm just destroying you with the shot
you know what I helped you with that
mutt fire death is lighting me up
hitting the brakes will fly right by
there we go were you at that are you are
you yeah
I don't think so just dunked your ass I
don't your ass then move on kid nobody
do tumbleweeds do anything bad you cuz I
just get killed my pleasure
I'm taking it basically these evasive
maneuvers I'm taking
magnetic projectile that's fun and it
not only hurts your car it also destroys
all your hard drives if you have any old
iPods kills those too
you can like go under my car I'm not
sure about the physics of this game
yeah oh my god carnage just carnage I
ain't all right
god I never dunked so many cookies and
milk in my life yeah line them up line
them up I think oh my god you got your
look they're not a motorcycle with a
chainsaw see ya well let's see about
that
oh hi bad I can't get out
yes oh yeah look at this that's glory
right oh my god that was awesome
oh wait there she is I'll try her over
how do I back up oh there you are I was
trying to get you guys in my sights I'm
trying to run her over here we go I
didn't do it you burn to death before I
could do it wait now I'm trapped in the
corner oh wait I figured out how to back
up which is the right stick yeah I just
go I just go forward man Oh forward yeah
I don't I don't look back I look forward
to killing everyone
sneaking up on you
oh yeah oh man oh my god dude here's the
thing about a motorcycle doesn't provide
a lot of cover for machine-gun fire I
don't we're recommending is might be
delayed wheelie with the motorcycle and
what kind of shots on fire and throw it
whoa I just saw it that was awesome
here's what I recommend turning around
because I'm just shooting you in your
ass oh oh wait let's run Robert oh yeah
blood splatter oh let's see you driving
real like that wow this is basically
just our good morning commute it's like
a la freeway
somebody's right on my ass it's a
chainsaw don't think I don't see that
chainsaw coming oh come on aah
[Applause]
and get out of here Sunday toughie weeds
in this town oh man
let's dig down oh really me pump
somebody's stack there we go
my god whoever player three days
dead my god six more minutes of this
should we stop and let Stephen in
Stephen your play Oh what all right
I think I think I think I'm pretty much
destroyed you guys no Beth you're still
playing Oh gonna play three round four
of us I'm put in the middle once again
everybody if you want it we're gonna try
to get Jordan to play next week so
hashtag Jordan play in the game you want
to see a lot of good suggestions so far
dance dance revelution farming simulator
outlast a lot of a lot of really great
not really good things exactly all right
here we go what all right so let's go
fast YouTube I think we're gonna go to
quit game that's how you actually exit
the game on purpose here we are more fun
all said you guys are the worst drivers
ever so Steve it's true all right let's
do let's do it
ten kills all right fifteen will do fine
unlimited weapons oh yeah how do we do a
limited weapons right there yes single
weapon no you sell some I know I think
you guys are also being called up for
control yeah that's my favorite thing
ever all right let's do it ready come oh
wait no let's where we going to play can
we play in that one that had all the
ramps and it's like a big future oh yeah
wait the key mean the Killa see em yeah
yeah Killa see him I love it should we
have other other people or no I guess we
can't do it all right here we go
yeah all right I'm up I'm up or left
what you're up Lisa's up or right
Beth is lower left and Stephen is lower
right I'm going with my I'm gonna go
with holy
it would be a holy man do it we don't
want to be on the same team though I
guess at this matter I'm gonna be your
boy who look at this Vermin that's a new
guy does that guy do all right those
rats at everybody whoa that's crazy at a
rat rocket Red Rocket oh my god is that
what I want to be I'm going to your boy
outlaw submachine gun no 12-gauge no
exclude flew mission wants you to flex
play I'm not gonna flex I'm gonna flex
my amazing that's weird cuz usually in
the office you love I love flexing
exactly in person it's great on camera
it's not impressive it's not a precedent
it's just gonna it's just gonna make me
look tough which is I already look down
so I know usually when you do it in the
office we're all just like wow very
impressive that's oh my god look at that
it's weight it's all the weapons oh I'm
not sure about this this might be too
crazy
this is just gonna be crazy death I mean
not that I'm complaining
unlimited weapons this is insane
I
because that's me just kill me I'm just
shooting unlimited homing missiles at
you no I'm not I'm deaf I I feel like
unlimited weapons just gonna be insane I
mean it'll be fine there we go let's see
how I find something else into my ass
Oh
Oh
where is everybody I can come and just
destroy them
my god everybody's over here you know
all I'm saying is if they made this show
in real life I would watch it kill
myself
targeted by laughing ghosts
oh boy
see you're doing the same thing I was
doing whoops whoops
oh now I'm a robot
oh nice I'm gonna go just explore the
Killa see him a little bit taking the
sights it's a pretty beautiful place can
be yeah especially this time of year
the laughing ghost has targeted what's
that I don't know but I who's the
Laughing ghost and lit up by the
Laughing ghosts earlier
you'll clear three Oh I'm just shooting
homing missiles everywhere all the time
oh man I be tired about laughing goes
this is Tom I got any hey us
I'm targeted by laughing ghosts I got
the Stuart
flex it right a PS now yeah this is on
PS now let's see the UH
I'm gonna beat Road boat here we go come
to Road vote
Aaron you look older here than you on
clueless gamer yeah I'm an old man an
old sad man that's also cuz I'm not
wearing any makeup
how about that Claire to kill it up huh
they were asking uh do you remember the
promo or Conan who dared you and they're
asking your fella scripted run oh that
was unscripted and he broke our side by
the way oh yeah that would that promo is
definitely unscripted he was just
supposed to say something and he just
like went crazy I mean it was really
funny that's also horrifying those tears
are heavy by the way you like whipped it
across the rim
whoo
this is fun ooh there we go
- all right all right I'm just shooting
myself it's somebody I'm a because
somebody else is the same cars right oh
here we go yeah all right over somebody
so fun
merci bonus
[Music]
Wow they wanted Flair - well done am i
clear - yeah yeah man oh man that was
great
who would have thought who would've
thought I think that's what it was you
finally start obsessing the bun just
like hey just damn alright well let's
play maybe not other around should we do
should we do unlimited weapons again
should be doing limited weapons again
there's a lot of what oh wait we're just
doing the same thing same thing wait
let's try let's try - I want to try a
different thing okay for Coliseum
absolutely matches smoothly kills -
mmhmm that's right
we don't oh yeah dump those Oreos we did
it give it the dumb wait maybe we go we
go
tap wait we go leo tap tap and then pull
it out of the bag and dunk it I don't
know I think we should tap tap
twist twist Oh dog oh yeah II already
have twist Doug nice that's how you do
it
alright here we go where should we play
where should we play the killing field
ghettoblaster vertigo or to go sighs
time where we go all right vertigo it is
wait this might be on top of buildings
hell yeah okay there's Merlin's madness
is a castle there or the killest and we
did Museum Massacre it's boring well we
don't have to learn stuff all right
should we do Merlin's madness or vertigo
either I would like to try either this -
Merlin's madness seems fun - another 5
10 kills unlimited weapons again yeah
yeah alright let's do it
boys always on
here we go I'm gonna be somebody I've
never been I've been the ice cream truck
yeah yeah turn to the robot that's
pretty cool good I'm gonna be that rat
guy this is dude the rat mofo let's do
it merlyn's madness today's thrills and
spills Adventure Park finally here we go
question do I really shoot rats dunno
get like crazy oh my god someone's
lighting me up already
I think I'm somewhere in the castle
greenery just can't see grass it has to
be greenery I'm in some green space I
see somebody
whoa shut up shut up
Earl it's bad business
who the hell is laughing ghost one of
the key targeting I hate I hate this
vehicle by the way this song
driving around Abu old castle
rodent rocket that's how I roll
oh I just got destroyed who's axel
that's me baby oh my god
oh my god it's got real he's real me
I seem trying to hit me getting out of
here boosters what we got here we are
homing missiles
easy-easy pause pause girl
she's explaining rice it's uncomfortable
playing games with opponent and you get
mad it it's not a cup I mean it's not
uncomfortable it's great
I do get mad at him though because he's
really bad it's just a lot of like me
saying let go to the left go II don't
know you said you go to go to the play a
lot of that you have to be very patient
it's like playing with like a baby it's
like a giant baby who then signs your
paychecks
it's kind of what it's like there's so a
giant baby that signs all you do work
for baby industries yeah how is your
baby industry going pretty good it's a
terrible job
yeah the management is all over the
place lunch breaks are long though yeah
that's what I take baths yeah they take
now it's nap time
experimenting these are the weapons
fetuses
I'm eating to think that special on this
thing is pretty lame I've been like
mailing people nobody wait what are you
on axle yeah I got hit you with the
crush
but it only does 60 man
see it's pretty good what's the missiles
like 8:30 oh Jesus oh yeah I got your
corpse I'm coming back as the Reaper
time to throw some chainsaws brain needs
naps this is not this is Ron PS now this
is not via left stick down to wheelie
gonna be a tie game
I'm not doing to all this game
Jade size 40 damage
I play a three slow on down
feel against a motorcycle I shouldn't be
ramming people I feel like that's a real
dumb boo but whatever
hey jumping yeah man flaming chainsaws
there we go yeah oh wait wait wait I hit
you the flaming chainsaw no I did bad I
think we all did kind of bad merlyn's
madness is no fun it's a tie game
between all of us
let's do the Vertigo one yeah that's you
vertigo let's do you vertigo all right
that would be our last thing here oh
wait I don't want to start let's see her
flaming RAM saw is exactly sweet flaming
Ram saws fling your emphasize new band
name brand new band name both bumpers to
jump exactly Oh both bumpers there we go
tie lol alright here we go
whoops I messed up sorry no so jumpy
like this twisted metals make me crazy I
here we go what what let's do there you
go amber go it is here we go 10 kills
guys this is for everything unlimited
weapons yeah yeah let's do it
yes damage damage
all right boom we're in alright pick
your best guy I'm going outlaw it's my
boy started for the bottom now we here
you know started at the bottom now we're
still at the bottom we go full squat on
squat great alright here we go
I started somebody started on top of me
and now you're gonna pay Oh already fell
off yeah die when you fall off yeah
I'm just falling player 3 around big
jump
or oh yeah died died wait what is
bumpers to job my kidding
what's happening here
might be am i moving backwards around
this is crazy I just fell out twice Beth
height Oh
[Music]
why would you drive around on top of
buildings doesn't make any sense
why would a drive an ice cream truck and
murder well I don't know he's listening
to his heart
I just got destroyed big-tire guys my
favorite shell box know my hair's not
dyed
it's a point grey when i was 14
I'm a freak whoa I keep getting like
something happening we're like the wind
is blowing me around or something yeah I
think I was like wind right oh I just
died again you've got to be kidding me
it's like terrible wind
oh that's not good that's not win-win
don't have bullets when was that was
Beth win don't have bullets
we don't have bullets oh look at that
there Christ air oh he's this guy oh
dude I've died like a thousand times
because the clowns are evil it's true
here we go here we go always had an
answer man why would I
I think so oh here we go right we're in
a big pit I'm in it I am some kind of
death pit somebody come here so I can
kill them get in the cage get in the
cage don't fall off the edge Oh
Wow Wow Wow what's happening there we go
now we're all like at the same place
oh man I get destroyed Jesus my worst
game ever you know what I'm learning
from this game don't drive my death
mobile on top of buildings it's not a
good place oh not a good place to be
[Music]
no the homing missiles really your
friend you know l1 and r1 select your
weapons by the way you see you guys know
you push towards the edge not gonna work
oh this thing is rotating I never got
that
I'm just randomly shooting missiles into
the city there we got older we get
blowup that crane nope oh my god
hey buddy oh my god this isn't a dome
we're outside
[Music]
oh yeah
that's me that's me
but outlaws special is just a a homing
gun it just constantly shoots a people
how you killed me I don't think I've
killed a single person the girls and the
girls are just like you destroyed this
man oh I finally killed one first way I
could we can't run somebody over at the
grin sticking yes exactly some victory
laps oh god that was awful
champion what happened I don't know what
happened there the games I don't know
what happened well that was a great day
of death for Monday melee thank you for
joining us
twitch and YouTube we had a great time
every Monday near you can join us here
at twitch.tv slash team cocoa and
youtube.com slash team cocoa and thank
you to Lisa Blair is a burn thank you
Steve Smith on the ones and twos changed
O'Malley over there the chat room slash
creeper style at best murasky in the
chat thank you for you guys joining us
please tweet at us
hashtag Jordan plays with a video game
that you want to see Jorge Lansky play
and I will do my best to get him here
next week and as always tweet at Team
Coco about what game you want to see on
clueless gamer there's a clueless gamer
coming up next week we're all very
excited about it and thanks for joining
us we will see you guys next week
you